So political,
we're mixing video is just a term that I made up to try to describe a whole set
of,
of video works.
They often will video works that they're appropriate,
uh,
material from other sources without permission throughout history,
this type of work has been called many things.
Uh,
some it's been called anti-art.
Um,
it's been called sub retirement.
Uh,
it's been called found footage.
It's been called appropriation art.
Um,
but uh,
when I,
when I was bringing that you need to sort of the current context and don't,
I was talking about it in terms of youtube.
It's something that,
um,
is,
is much more,
more popular.
People are looking at television and they're saying,
you know what,
I don't want this to be a one way relationship anymore.
I don't want this to be just me watching a,
I have something to say and I want to say it in the language of TV.
I want to say it in the language of radio.
I want to say it in the language of the movies.
And so I'm going to take that,
I'm going to mix it up and I'm going to do it for a,
for a purpose.
It can often be funny,
but it's not just to be funny.
Hey,
it has social commentary involved.
And so when I say political remix,
um,
what I mean is that it,
it,
it's a commentary on,
uh,
on society.
It's a commentary on culture.
It's a commentary on politics.
Um,
and when I say politics,
I mean gender,
class,
race,
sexuality,
uh,
economy,
and then also government.
But government is a smaller part,
I think of that,
of that thing.
So,
um,
I also call it a subversive remix.
Video was another name for it.
So I began remixing video,
uh,
back in 2003 when the Iraq war was,
was beginning,
you know,
in the United States,
at least the,
the mass media,
they were just cheerleaders,
you know,
they were really excited.
They were like,
this is,
you know,
there was like a game for them and they got to talk about all the guns and the
different kinds of guns.
And they were really excited,
you know?
And then it would cut to commercial and it would be,
uh,
you know,
buy this truck,
you're too fat.
You need to go to Mcdonald's or whatever.
Um,
and,
and it would come back and say,
Oh,
20 people died.
No pictures of course,
but 20 people died,
30 people died.
Um,
and so it,
it,
it became a really,
you know,
in my mind,
the very sick game that they were playing in a 32nd spots.
So I would take the foot of some footage from.com documentary film footage,
some footage from the news and some footage of the,
of these ads and make new ads.
Um,
I started with making new army ads for the U s army.
and I replaced the,
for the footage and the audio is still there,
but a place to footage.
And I always say to people,
you want to Remix,
start remixing,
mixing ads,
make them more truthful.
You know,
what's what I would call identity correction.
Correct.
The identity of this ad.